hello and welcome to this video playing
the Rainmaker mmm okay what is he doing
here said all up zip I don't really
loves a beer so yeah my current ratings
slump makes me a huge under talk in this
game even though I usually beat him 10
out of 17 I got knight c6 year okay hmm
now what to do here ok let's and it's
play d4 get the space always like
spaceman so what is this this idea of
players are taking and go and five it's
pretty much well known from many other
openings particular the closest alien
what is 83 about will see an aged 6 is
about 95 I don't want 95 to happen let's
see I'm playing oh wow
hmm not very not something very that
expected him that he did do something on
the queenside him hmm quite surprising
mmm wait to put this night may be here
Pepsi for IDs here ok now I'm plane see
phone and see what happens so pretty
quickly played but cage hmm
let's see what he does takes with the
night now probably one takes I've got d3
even though I'm taking on anyone yeah
probably still well what a mess what a
complete mess
I don't know maybe it's atique with the
poem
my eggs are also have some other books
that look very decent yeah of course I
mean you can do it but instead c95 is
definitely part of this position maybe
just this one ideas Bishop takes h5 and
if you take syd night takes and
threatening night except for ham
we don't really believe in this wide
position to be honest okay it's very
tactical or so there might be concrete
things going on that make this okay for
white but all in all I feel like his
loose Charlie Lewis position yeah I'm
attacking a 4 here
kim night at four
can take twice plane 85
so let get let's get this into play as
well I don't see him covering f4 anyway
I threat now is 94 d takes e4 9f for
taking it let's say conveniently
maybe it's trying for something to
irritate you with 95 still night XD for
the night x f4 is a very strong thread
ok took it so night takes a four or not
I also take this first I cannot be bad
so what what now I can still take is
good it's got Queenie for check
yeah but all this is good anyway you
know I don't have to don't have to be a
very hectic about it it's got some some
issues there as well anyway I mean f4
and ce4 I've got 95 I just dropped back
it's not an issue
check right before yeah that's a good
idea okay night f1 now check let's grab
stuff okay um if I take and then d3d
three King up in which it
white resigns okay ja very complicated
game I think look kind of okay but it
was very very tough to play for sure
everything was like let's say the whole
board was involved in this complicated
position each form I went c4 rather
quickly to get come out to play and he
went here and took it now this is this
is around here we are talking about the
critical situations he played this and
after Bishop g4 the engine starts to
like my position which doesn't surprise
me I was pretty happy here the engine
gives at this as a good idea check yeah
yeah some something like that might
might work takes bishop chicks for Queen
age 50 the engine says this is equal it
with King g8 bishop here bishop f7 and
this is supposed to be equal it's not
really what comes to mind for a human
player wow yeah can analyze this but
it's a whole different game okay this
Bishop g4 check take sim engine doesn't
like that at all it wants to take c form
and still gives them evaluate this is
roughly equal
yeah marking them okay I mean the engine
at depth 23 I don't really trust much
check when it gives black a small
advantage but this is also what i think
is correct but soon yeah here it gives
black cleared a clear advantage and it's
really difficult if we want to find
something 96 yeah engine wants to do
this this is stronger because latex c5
isn't even possible yeah that would have
been stronger this is already winning
for black I'm threatening this nightie
for a night f4 ok so here you just he
could take and continue ok I just took
it sim simple moves engine gives equal I
don't believe that simply I mean not in
a human players game blacks play as much
easier asking as more insecure and he's
got this problem with the bishop on c1
and the game if he fell apart pretty
quickly 91 still seems to be very tough
oh no no it gives Queenie 6 with black
bean burger check and here here here i
think it is a check it is basically
losing as I'm threatening group takes e4
now this is winning with the pawns yeah
tough game but I'm pretty happy with it
I think it had pretty decent control
over proceedings here okay well thanks
for watching